this nation has been plagued with
football heartbreak
for years but today that germany-shaped
barrier was shattered
leading up to this critical game the
nerves the excitement
was felt everywhere england sensed their
moment to shake off the weight of
history
against germany a feeling all too
familiar for john
malad wanted the england euro 96 year
i said i've got it i've got it i've not
worried since because we've been beat it
hurt me that much
they piled into this fan zone in
manchester many who weren't even born on
that fateful night
25 years ago how's it been over the last
25 years for you been heartbreaking
it's been heartbreaking nothing but
failure left right now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it was of course the now england
manager's notorious penalty miss
against germany at wembley in the euro
96 semi-final
unlike today there was no social
distancing back then
fans swarmed the streets hoping for a
spot in the final
but even a pandemic couldn't stop the
celebrations
of this iconic national moment
looks like the kurds of germany is
broken
and football but these fans may well be
coming home
[Music]
an england player for 11 years wes brown
only knows the suffering
the national side has faced when we
played germany you know it's always a
big game everyone's always up for it the
fans understand it
but it's always a difficult one as well
yeah we've won some big ones in the past
but in general in tournament play you
know it's been hard
and the delirious celebrations were not
just for the relief of this historic
victory
but perhaps the pleasure of celebrating
together
after so long apart we did have the most
expectations for this game i don't
think we're all just buzzing we've
waited
29 years for england to have this
promise and we literally
cannot wait
[Applause]
[Music]
for many across the country this game
felt like a final
fans wondered whether a win would ever
come and it did
the power of football has before
delivered moments that bring people
together in agony
but today pure ecstasy intermittent
rasheed sky news
manchester